[موسيقى]
اسبوع بالكامل مر على الانقلاب العسكري في
النيش ولا يزال التوتر والترقب ويا
السودان البلاد ومنطقه الساحل الافريقي
برمتها قبل الانقلاب بالادانه على المستوى
الدولي وتحذيرات من تدهور الاوضاع بشكل
اكبر في حاله عدم التوصل الى صيغه توافقيه
لاعاده النظام الدستوري في البلاد عبر
المفاوضات او في حال اي تدخل عسكري خارجي
قد يعمق الازمه ويعقد الجهود والمساعي
التي تبذل الاحتوائها فما هي اذا الخيارات
المتاحه لدى القاده العسكريين الجدد وهل
ينجحون في فرض الامر الواقع واحكام
سيطرتهم رغم الضغوط والعقوبات الاقتصاديه
وكيف ستنعكس هذه الازمه المتفاقمه على
الوضع الداخلي في النيجر وعلى الامن
والاستقرار في منطقه الساحل الافريقيه
الهشه والمضطربه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه
من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ثلاثه ايام تفصلنا عن المهله
التي حددتها دول المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب
افريقيا المعروفه اختصارا باسم اكواس قبل
ان تلجا الى ما سمته الخيار الاخير اي
الخيار العسكري في حال اصرار القاده
العسكريين الجدد على رفض اعاده السلطه الى
الرئيس المخلوع محمد بازو
لمعرفه الخيارات المطروحه امام كل الاطراف
في هذه الازمه المتفاقمه والمسارات
المحتمله لها خلال الايام والاسابيع
المقبله يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه
الحلقه الدكتوره ادريس ايات الاكاديميه
النيجيريه والباحث المختص في شؤون الساحل
الافريقي من واكشوط محمد عبد الله طالب
عبيدي الباحث في الشؤون الامنيه لمنطقه
الساحلي والصحراء
ومن باريس نيكولا نور السفير الفرنسي
السابق في دول افريقيه عديده من بينها
مالي وهو حاليا ينشر مقالات في صحف ومجلات
فرنسيه ولديهم مؤلفات عديده من بينها
الكتاب الكتاب الكبير
لافريقيا
الانقلاب العسكري الذي شهدته النيجر هو
خامس كلاب تشهده البلاد منذ استقلالها عن
فرنسا عام
1960 انقلاب ياتي في سياق موجه جديده من
انقلابات والانقلابات المضاده شهدتها دول
منطقه الساحل الافريقي خلال العامين
الماضيين فقط
منذ عام 2020 وحتى اواخر عام 2022 سجلت
دور القاره الافريقيه سته انقلابات عسكريه
ناجحه في تشاد ومالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا
وقع انقلباني الاول وفي اغسطس 2020 حين
اطاحت مجموعه من الضباط بالرئيس المنتخب
ابراهيم بوبكر كايتا
والثاني في مايو 2021 حين ازاح العقيد طه
الحكومه المشكله بعد الانقلاب وتولى رئاسه
البلاد وفي بوركينا فاسو وقع انقلابان
ايضا الاول في يناير 2022 حين استولى
المقدم بولو على السلطه واطاح بالرئيس
المنتخب روشمر كابوري والثاني في الثلاثين
من سبتمبر من العام نفسه اي بعد ثمانيه
اشهر فقط انقلبت مجموعه من الضباط على
دانيبا واختارت نقيب ابراهيم تراوري رئيس
جديد للمجلس العسكري وبذلك تكون هو
بوركينا فاسو قد سجلت رقما قياسيا في
الانقلابات العسكريه بلغ عددها تس عه
انقلابات دون احتساب المحاولات الانقلابيه
الفاشله
وقدمت كل من الولايات المتحده والاتحادان
الاوروبي والافريقي هذه الانقلابات كما
علقت عضويه كل من بوركينا فاسو ومالي
والنيجر في مجموعه دول الاكواس اثر ذلك
هذه الانقلابات التي شهدتها دول الساحل
الافريقيه واخرها في النيجر تشير الى تركز
الانقلابات العسكريه في هذه المنطقه خلال
السنوات الاخيره وتسارع وتيرتها بشكل اكبر
من قبل وهو ما دفع دول مجموعه الى الشروع
في تطبيق العقوبات الاقتصاديه والتلويح
بالخيار العسكري في حال عدم التوصل الى حل
توافقه
اكثر مما حدث في اي بلد افريقي اخر تضيق
الدائره على منفذي الانقلاب في النيجر
تلوح دول في المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب
افريقيا اكواس بتدخل عسكري لاعاده الرئيس
محمد بازوم الى السلطه
تلك خطوه قد تلقى ان وقعت ايد قوى دوليه
في مقدمتها فرنسا والولايات المتحده لكن
الاوان لم يحن بعد لهذا الخيار ثم تعقوبات
بدات فعليا تؤثر على حياه الناس فقد توقفت
امدادات الكهرباء من نيجيريا وبدات كوت
ديفوار وبنين تطبيق العقوبات الاقتصاديه
التي فرضتها على ميامي لم يسلم المجتمع
الدولي بسهوله اذا للانقلاب كما حدث من
قبل في مالي وبوركينا فاسو في العامين
الماضيين عندما تحول الانقلاب الى امر
واقع انها بالنسبه للجيش في النيجر مرحله
الارتباك في اتخاذ خيار الخطوه التاليه
فالمضي قدما الى الامام سيزيد المتاعب
الاقتصاديه التي تسببها العقوبات بينما
سيكون التراجع فشلا ذريعا وضربه موجعه
لقيادات الصف الاول في المؤسسه العسكريه
هل سيعولون على مواقف مالي وبوركينا فاسو
وغينيا هل معارضه لاي تدخل عسكري ذلك ان
البلدان الثلاثه اعلنت انها لن تلتزم
بالعقوبات وذهبت باماكو ووجدو الى درجه
التحذير من انهما ستعتبران اي تدخل عسكري
في النيجر اعلان حرب ضدهما
هذا شرخ في المواقف داخل مجموعه اكواس
ربما يوفر بعض الوقت لصمود منفذي لانقلاب
في النيجر وقد يتيح الفراغ الذي سيخلفه
الانسحاب الفرنسي من البلد مساحه شديده
للنفوذ الروسي المتزايد في منطقه الساحل
فهناك توسع شركه فاجنر دائره انتشارها
باسماء مختلفه لدعم النظم العسكريه
الناقمه على الوجود الفرنسيه لكن البلد
ايضا نقطه التقاء شبكه من المصالح
الاقتصاديه والامنيه للقوه الغربيه وقد
يجعل ذلك الضغط الغ اقوى ولان البلد من
بين الافقر في العالم ومرتهن للمساعدات
الماليه الغربيه فاثروا العقوبات
الاقتصاديه المفروضه عليه موجع لذا ينظر
الى خيارات سياسيه اخرى كمخارج محتمله من
الازمه هل يلجا العسكر الى اشراك الطبقات
السياسيه في رسم خطه تمهد الانتخابات تعيد
البلد الى السكه الدستوريه وتقنع المجتمع
الدولي بالبدء في رفع العقوبات
لكن حقيقه ان الرئيس محمد بازوم محتفظ
بمنصبه ولم يقدم استقالته ويحظى فوق هذا
بدعم دولي كبير من باريس واشنطن تجعل
الحديث عن مرحله انتقاليه امرا معقده
ومحفوفا بالموانع الدستوريه
نرحب بضيوفنا ثلاثه ولكن نبدا من نيامي
موقع الحدث ومراسلنا هناك فضل عبد الرزاق
فضل ضعنا في اجواء
المزاج العام الشعبي وهو ينتظر هذه
العقوبات
الاقتصاديه التي
بعضها دخل حيز التطبيق
نعم المزاج العام استاذ محمد حتى الان هو
في جزء منه هو ما يظهره المجلس العسكري من
مظاهرات وتحيد له وهذا التاييد يشمل
مؤسسات مهنيه وكذلك
جمعيات لرجال اعمال وكل هذا المنحى هو
يركز في
التنديد بالعقوبات التي فرضت هم يتحدثون
عن ان هذه العقوبات تؤثر على الشعب بشكل
اكبر والحقيقه العقوبات التي فرضت هي
عقوبات من نوعين تلك التي اعلنتها مجموعه
غرب افريقيا المعروفه اقتصارا باكوس وتشمل
اغلاق الحدود الجويه وهي في اغلب الاحيان
المطارات استخدامها في النيجر محدود
ويستخدمها النخبه فقط يعني تقريبا طائره
او طائرتين كل يوم تهبط في مطار ميامي
وفقط وبالتالي
فالمتاثرين بالعقوبات مثل اغلاق الحدود
الجويه محدود اذا ما نقيسه تاثيره على
الشعب
العقوبات الاخرى الخاصه
بالمجال البري
نقل الصادرات البضائع منها ومن نادر
واليها هي التي يمكن ان يكون لها تاثير
على الناس على حياتهم العاديه التاثير
الاكبر ليس على العقوبات التي فرضتها
مجموعه غرب افريقيا
انما المجموعه النقديه لغرب افريقيا وهي
مجموعه الفرنك
النيجر جزء من هذه المجموعه اي ان ليس
لديها نقد انما تتبع للبنك المركزي
لمجموعه غرب افريقيا هذه المجموعه ايضا
فرضت عقوبات البنوك المصارف التي تفتح في
النيجر يجب ان يكون لديها تصريح من البنك
المركزي لغرب افريقيا والتعليمات كلها تصل
من هناك اذا ما قرر البنك المركزي لدول
الغربيه افريقيا في مجموعه الفرنك
اغلاق المصارف فهذا يعني فعلا انه كف يد
المجلس العسكري للوصول الى كل النقد الذي
هو متوفر للدوله حتى الان لم يتم تنفيذ
هذه الاجراءات وان كان انه اعلن بان
مجموعه غرب افريقيا النقديه ايضا اعلنت
العقوبات على النادر لكن حتى الان لم يتم
المباشره في هذا الامر بالتالي ما تزال
المصارف متاحه
للاناث ونقول ان هذا سيكون لديه تاثير
كبير لانه عن طريق هذه الموارد يمكن الدفع
بما في ذلك الرواتب الجنود وكذلك الرواتب
الموظفين العاديين للدوله الذين هم الان
عادوا الى العمل
العمل الان الامناء العاملين اي وكلاء
الوزارات في الدوله اذا ما قرر فعلا وقف
او تجميد كل الحسابات ولا يمكن للمجلس
العسكري الوصول الى النقد فهذا يعني انه
لن يكون قادرا على دفع حتى الرواتب
وبالتالي التاثير سيكون كبير مع ان هذا
سيكون فيه مخاطره ايضا لان الاصوات التي
ترتفع
لطرد فرنسا من النيجر هي تتحدث ايضا عن ان
العمله هذه التي تسير النيجر وبقي البلدان
غربي افريقيا التي استعمرتها فرنسا سابقا
هي عمله استعماريه لمصالح فرنسا
والمطالب حتى قبل الانقلاب وحتى قبل
انقلاب مالي ايضا هناك مظاهرات في الشوارع
تطالب بالخروج من هذه العمله وتكوين عمله
خاصه بهذه البلدان فاذا ما طبقت هذه
العقوبات بشكل قد يجرها ايضا الى ان يكون
كخطوه عكسيه وهو المطالبه بالخروج من هذه
العمله تفضل شكرا لك ستبقى معنا سنعود
اليك عندما نتطرق الى سيناريو الخيار
العسكري نبقى اذا في موضوع العقوبات نسال
الدكتور ادريس ايات
النيجر من افقر الدول في العالم
تعيش بالاساس على المساعدات
المختلفه والتي تصل حسب البنك الدولي
تقريبا الى اثنين مليار دولار اذا ما طبقت
هذه العقوبات ومثلا البنك الدولي اوقف كل
تعاملات الماليه هل الناس لديها قدره على
الصمود
نعم تاهيه طيبه لك استاذ وتهيه خاصه لتاكل
من قناه الجزيره
وايضا المشاهدين الكرام نعم الحقيقه ان
الراي العام في جمهوريه النيجر منقسم الى
قسمين هناك قسم يرى ان باعتبار ان الدوله
اصلا الدوله غير مراقبه ودوله على تقريبا
90% منها تتعامل على الطرق القديمه
والمقايدات اضف الى ذلك انه
استعمال البنوك والمؤسسات الرسميه هذه
نادره ما يوظف الا من قبل الموظفين
الرسميين والنخبه السياسيه قد تكون
تاثيرها على الشاب محدودا اما فيما يتعلق
بالنخبه السياسيه فهي منقسمه الى قسمين
هناك قسم يرى انه استحاله تحمل ما تحملته
مثلا جمهوريه مال المجاوره وخاصه ان
جمهوريه النيجر المساعدات التي ذكرتم يمثل
قرابه 22 الى 30% من المساعدات الخارجيه
فاذا ما توقفت
يحتمل يحتملوا ان يكون هناك
تحمل لبعض الوقت لكن اذا ما طال الامر قد
يؤدي ذلك الى تكوين الجبهه الداخليه تعارض
هذا المجلس العسكري واعتقدوا ان هذا هو
الرهان الذي يحاول او تحاول مجموعه اقواس
العمل عليه ان تكون هناك جبهه داخليه يتم
دعمها لاسقاط الانقلابيين نعم
على كل قائد الانقلاب العسكري وهنا اسهل
السيد نيكولا نورمان قائد الانقلاب
العسكري قال لن نخضع للضغوط وقال بان هذه
العقوبات غير عادله غير انسانيه غير
مسبوقه هل تعتقد بان سلاح العقوبات يمكن
ان يحكم
المعادله ويجبر
الانقلابيين على التراجع
اولا اعتقد ان العقوبات فعلا ثبت ان كفاءه
عده مرات خاصه في مالي في 2012 عندما كان
انقلاب وانسحب وايضا في مالي ايضا في غرب
افريقيا في
2017 كان الرئيس قد ف خسر الانتخابات
ولكنه بقى بالسلطه بفضل العقوبات واما
النيجا تعتمد الى حد كبير على المساعدات
الخارجيه
وبالتالي في العقوبات تكون اكثر فعاليه ما
حصلت في مالي وغيرها واضافه ان العقوبات
ستكون اقسى من مالي لان هناك
ضغوط كبيره من رئيس نيجيريا الذي هو
لانه هو هدد حتى بتدخل عسكري وبالتالي
هناك ضغوط اكثر مما حصل في السابق فيما
يتعلق على غينيا ومالي او بوركينا فاسو
وكل هذا يمكن ان يؤدي او يسمح بمغادره
الانقلابيين واذا لم يحصل ذلك فورا فذلك
سيؤدي الى وضع اخلال باستقرار البلاد وهذا
لكم مفيدا للانقلابيين على المدى البعيد
وبالتالي ستدخل وسيدخلونا فتره من
الاضطرابات وبالتالي ثم هناك
مكافحه الجهاديه اقتضعف والرئيس مازون كان
كفؤا جدا في صراعه ضد الجهاديين فهو كان
يقود عملا عسكريا
ماليه من بينها مثلا المساعدات الامريكيه
200 مليون دولار هل تعتقد بان
في النهايه هذا السلاح لن يكون فعالا لانه
لن يمس العسكريين لن يمسهم وبالتالي الشعب
هو الذي سيتضرر وبالتالي السلاح وقد لا
يكون فعانا مئه بالمئه
مساء الخير مساء الخير لدينا تحليل لكم
موضوعي تماما اذا اكيد ان هذه العقوبات
كما تعلمون الدعم دعم الميزانيه التي الذي
تقدمه فرنسا والاتحاد الاوروبي والمانيا
يمثل 60% من الميزانيه وخاصه في سته اشهر
الاخيره يعني حتى نهايه السنه ولا يمكن ان
تتحمل يعني عقوبات اقتصاديه ضد ضدها طيله
هذه الفتره كما قلتم لان ذلك يعني الشعب
البسيط والموظفين وقد لا يكون
كافيا وراجعا للمجموعه العسكريه التي
اخذت السلطه خاصه انها تتلقى دعم من بعض
القيادات الانقلابيه في دول المشاوره مثل
ذلك الدعم بالاساس ودعم معنوي وان يكون لا
عسكري ولا للصعوبات التي تواجهها هذه
القوه لانه بدون شك سيكون هنالك لزاما ان
يقع يعني ضغط اقوى لحمل الانقلابيين على
تسليم السلطه نعم الدكتور اياد في موضوع
العقوبات الاقتصاديه ايضا المساله ليست
فقط انقطاع الكهرباء الوارد الى النيجر من
نيجيريا وقد بدا فعلا هناك بعض المشاريع
الكبرى التي قد تتعطل من بينها خط الانبوب
الغاز الذي سيمر عبر النيجر من نيجيريا
الى النيجر فالجزائر ثم الى اوروبا
عبر المتوسط تكلفته عشره الاف عشره مليار
دولار
طوله 4000 كيلو متر هذا المشروع سيتضرر
منه النيجر اذا اذا تعطل هل هذا يمكن ان
يكون سلاح قوي في ضمن العقوبات
نعم استاذ قبل الاجابه على هذا السؤال
احتاج فقط 10 ثواني لاوضها النقطه من سفير
السفير الفرنسي السابق في مالي باعتبار
انه
دعايات التي تدعي بان الرئيس بازون كان
ناجها في مكافات الارهابيين وغير هذا ليس
صحيحا والامر كان هناك تدورات المتزايده
حتى مع التعاون الفرنسي والغربي وخاصه في
منطقه تلابيري وهذا المواطنون العاديين هم
الذين يستشهدون بذلك فمحاوله بنينه كانه
الرجل كان في محاوله اصلاحيه امنيه او
سياسيه هذه ليست حقيقه اما فيما يتعلق
بموضوعك هذا الموضوع هو موضوع متعدد
الجوانب استاذ انا اعتقد انه ليست قوه بيد
الدول وخاصه الدول المجاوره التي تعامل
معاقبه الانقلابيين بقدر ما هي النقطه قوه
لدى الانقلابيين فالمستفيد منه النيجر
دوله ممر لكن المستفيد ممنون والم
الرئيسيين ليسوا حتى نيجيريين
بان اي تدخل عسكري او عقوبات قاسيه قد
يبرر منافع الربحيه اللي تلكم الدول فضلا
قبل ان يتدرج جمهوريه النيجر اذا في نهايه
المطاف يجب ان تتعلم تلكم الدول
بالمسؤوليه اولا عن هذه المنافع والمشاريع
الكبرى قبل ما تملي على الدوله التي ترى
ان اقوى الدول المجاوره انها يدل فرنسيه
لا اكثر تحاول ارداقها باعتبار انك كانت
هناك امور مماثله في دول المجاوره لكن
الامور العقوبات لم تكن قاسيه لهذا الدرج
والنبض الشعري لا يجب الاستهانه به لانه
يفكر على النحل بديهي والنهو البديهي يكون
اذا لم يتدخلوا عسكريا لم تكون قاسيه في
بوركينا فاسغينيا لماذا في النيجر التفسير
الوحيد الذي وجدوه ان هناك ايادي غربيه
خاصه الفرنسيه وهذا ما يفسر مهاجمه
السفاره الفرنسيه نعم لا اعتقد ان
المشاريع القبله اغربها اما المستفيده
منها هي الدول الخارجيه قبل ان تكون دوله
النيجر نعم
طالما موضوع العقوبات الاقتصاديه على
الاقل تاثيرها الان ليس واضحا بما يكفي في
موضوع التدخل العسكري هناك تلويح به واضح
مع مهله محدده اطلقتها الاكواس هنا نعود
مره اخرى لمراسلنا في نيام فضل عبد الرزاق
لنسى الماء اذا كان الناس هناك لديهم فعلا
خوف من ان تتطور الامور فعلا الى تدخل
عسكري ضد الانقلابين
نعم بالفعل كثير من الذين تحدثت معهم في
الشارع هنا في النيابه لا يستبعدون ان
تقوم
مجموعه بلدان غرب افريقيا
بتدخل
عسكري لانهم يعتقدون طالما ان هذا تم
الترويح به فالاحتمال قد لا يكون مستبعد
ويستبعدون ايضا ان يكون تدخل غربي مباشر
بحكم الاحتقان
وجهه النظر الشعبيه اصلا الرافضه لهذا
التدخل الغربي المباشر فقد يدفع المجتمع
الدولي ايضا كله باتجاه دعم مجموعه اكواس
بحيسان هي التي تتدخل لكن الاشكال الاساسي
الكل يتحدث عن تجربه مجموعه الاكواز
بالنسبه للتدخل العسكري حتى الان
صحيح ان تدخلت في عدد من البلدان عسكريا
ولكنها لم تستطع اعاده رئيس بالقوه الى
منصبه كل ما كان يجري هو يعني النموذج
الابرس ونموذج غامبيا وهو ايضا كان على
الحدود مع
السنغال وكانت تهديد باستخدام القوه وليس
انه كان تدخلا مباشرا رغم انه تم تحريك
كثير من القوات الى منطقه الحدود وحتى
انها بدات في الدخول الى غامبيا ولكن ايضا
كان للسنغال الدور الاساسي بحكم انها
لديها مصالح مباشره في
غامبيا هل يتوفر او تتوفر بلد من ضمن
مجموعه بلدان غربي افريقيا لديها مصالح
مشابهه بتلك التي لدى السنغال في دوله
السنغال عسكري بهذه القوه نعم على ذكر
السنغال هي نفسها ايضا وزيره الخارجيه
قالت بان بلادها ستش ارك سترسل قوات في
حال
قررت الاكواس التدخل العسكري يعني السنغال
حتى في هذه الحاله
اعربت عن استعدادها للتدخل
السنغال المتحفزه جدا واعلنت ذلك بل وجيش
نيجيريا ايضا اعلن اليوم في بيان ينفي
المعلومات التي كانت متداوله بان
تمت التعليمات واعطيت التعليمات للجيش
بالتحرك باتجاه الحدود مع النادر كان ينفي
هذا هذه التعليمات ولكنه وضع ايضا بان
قاده اركان الجيش يدرسون امكانيه وضع خطه
لتدخل عسكري والاولويه ستكون للحلول
الدبلوماسيه وطبعا الحلول الدبلوماسيه هي
التي كانت الخيار الاساسي بالنسبه للتعامل
مع
مايل كانت الخيار الاساسي بالنسبه للتعامل
مع بوركينا فاسو وهي الخيار الاساسي
بالنسبه للتعامل مع غينيا فهل التحديد
باستخدام القوه سيكون تهديد من اجل الدفع
بالخيارات الدبلوماسيه الى الامام ام انه
سيكون خيارا حقيقيا ويتم الشروع فيه من
الصعب تخيل ذلك لانه لا يوجد نموذج لدوله
يمكن الاشاره اليها بانها دوله لديها من
المصالح ما يكفي للتضحيه بما في ذلك
الخسائر والسمعه التي يمكن ان تواجه اي
تدخل عسكري مباشر وحل ايضا اذا ما تم
التدخل هل سوف يكون لاسقاط الحكم العسكري
ام الامكان اعاده الرئيس محمد بازون هنا
ايضا الخيارات صعبه بالنسبه للعسكريين
الذين ما زالوا يدرسون حتى اليوم لم ينتهي
اتباعهم هل اي تدخل عسكري سوف يؤدي الى
اعاده بزوم محمد الرئيس محمد بازون الى
السلطه ام انه سيسقط فقط الحكم العسكري
ولكن سيكون
الرئيس الجديد وليس الرئيس محمد بازون كل
هذه الخيارات من ضمن الاشياء التي تصعب
خيار التدخل العسكري وكثيرين يرون انه هو
من اجل الدفع بالخيارات الاخرى الى الامام
والوصول الى حل اكثر من انه يكون خيارا
واقعيا شكرا لك فضل عبد الرزاق وضعتنا في
سوره الاجواء هناك في النيجر سواء فيما
يتعلق بالعقوبات او فيما يتعلق بالاستعداد
لاحتمال تدخل عسكري شكرا لك سؤالك الذي
قلته الان فضل عبد الرزاق اسال عنه السفير
نيكولا نورمان في حال
وقوع التدخل العسكري هل تراه لاعاده
الرئيس محمد بازون بالضروره
اذا ما حصل تدخل عسكري فذلك بالتاكيد
سيكون لاعاده الرئيس مازون الى منصبه
حاليا هناك رئيسا في هذا البلد فهناك رئيس
قانوني شرعي لم يستقله رئيس مازوم وهناك
رئيس الواقعي الذي اخذ رئاسه بالقوه وليس
هناك اي اسماء او اي وبالتالي لنجد انه
كان هناك توافق شخصي رئيس شادي
تستولى على السلطه
بالتقاعد ولهذا السبب والجيش تردد كثيرا
في موافق عليه اكثر من 24 ساعه وبالتالي
باب التضامن ما بين العسكريين انضمت جيش
الى الانقلابيين لكن الواضح انهم غير
متحمسون وحتى مقسمون فيما بينهم فاذا حصل
التدخل العسكري وهو ليس بسنادوه المرغوب
بل هو اسوء السيناريوهات وهل مقالته منظمه
افريقيا
لكن لو اضطروا رغم كل شيء الا التدخل
العسكري فذلك بالتاكيد سيكون سيكون عمليه
صعبه الا اذا ان الانقلابين اذا ما شاهدوا
الجيوش الاقليميه النيجيريه والسنغاليه
وغيرها يصلون الى بلادهم فانهم قد
يستسلموا فورا ولكن وهذا غير مستبعد لكن
من الصعب نتصور معركه بين القاده الفارق
خاصه لما كان قاده النيجر ونيجيريا هم
غالبا يكون من نفس المجموعه العرقيه روسيا
وبالتالي لا يرغبون حقنا في القتال فيما
بينهم على الارجح واذا لابد محاوله تجنب
هذا السيناريو ولكن مهما كان السيناريو
وخاصه اذا كان اذا استمر الانقلابيون في
السلطه فان الجهادين هم الذين سيستفيدون
لان مثل هذه الازمه على مستوى العاصمه مع
تعليق المساعدات الخارجيه الدوليه
لمصلحه الجهاديين بشكل كبير لانه سيستغلون
هذا الموقف كما اظن لابد لابد ذكر ان
النيجر هي البلد لا قلت تاثرا كل منطقه
الساحل الوسطى فيها اقل عدد من ضحايا اللي
مقارنه بين بوركينا فاسو مالي وفي هذان
البلدان الوضع تدهور الجديد كثيرا بعد
انقلابين الاصل فيهما وبالتالي لابد تتجنب
تكرار ذلك
ضد رئيس انتخب انتخابيا كما هو الحال
بالنسبه للذي في نيجيريا وفي موريتانيا
يخافون من العدوى العدوى ان الامر يصل
بلدانهم ايضا فاذا
كل الدول في غرب افريقيا المنتخبون يخافون
تكرار ذلك لان العسكريين
بعمل الماتل في بلدانهم ايضا اذا كان
السفير نورما سيد عبيدي يركز هذه للمره
الثانيه على موضوع الجهاديين وموضوع
محاربه الارهاب كما تسمى هناك هناك ايضا
قضيه اخرى يخشى منها في حال التدخل
العسكري وهو تدفق المهاجرين بين الجزائر
والنيجر حدود تقريبا بالف كيلو متر
والجزائر حذره في هذا الموضوع لانها تخشى
انه اذا تم اللجوء الى الخيار العسكري فقد
يتدفق عشرات الالاف من النيجر الى الجزائر
في حين ان الان هناك دوريات مشتركه وهناك
اتفاقيات بين البلدين لمحاربه الهجره
السريه والتهريب وغير ذلك هل هذا الاحتمال
وارد
طبعا هنالك في حاله وقع التدخل العسكري
هنالك عده سناريوهات اولا يجب ان نشير
من المجموعه العربيه وهي اقليه في النيجر
قبل قبل
استلامه للسلطه كانت هنالك محاوله
انقلابيه وفي الدوله العميقه النيجيريه
هنالك ضباط يرفضون استيلاءه وصوله للسلطه
ولو بالطرق الديمقراطيه على نوارا لوصوله
للعربيه وهذا قد تكون رده فعل وهو عوده
التمرد في الشمال
ما قد يدعم ايضا الحركه
الحركات الجهاديه
المنتشره الان في مالي وفي بوركينا وشيماء
ولكن في النيجر تدفق المهاجرين ليس فقط
الجزائر وانما ايضا الى ليبيا وعلى كل حال
اعتقد ان اي تدخل
ستكون له عواقب جد سلبيه ولكن ايضا في
حاله عدم التدخل
ستكون الدول الغربيه
الاخرى عرضه للتغييرات غير الدستوريه وهي
عدم استقرار اكبر وكما تعلمون
اضطرابات
سياسيه قويه قد تكون فرصه للعسكريين
للاستيلاء على السلطه وربما ايضا في
بوركينا والدول الاخرى وبالتالي اعتقد ان
ليكو واصل الان تدرس جدا امكانيه بعض الحد
للتغييرات غير دستوريه لما قد
تشكله من خطر على استقرار هذه البلدان
خاصه ان الانقلابات التي تتم ايضا تشكل
تغيرا للمنحه السياسي لاحظنا ان العسكريين
الذين استولوا على السلطه في النيجر
موالون شيئا مالي توجه الروسي حيث اول
خطاب قاله رئيس عبد الرحمن وان المقاربه
المعتمده حتى الان لم تكن جديه تكون ذات
فائده وانه يطمح الى تغيير
المقاربه يجعلها اكثر نجاح هو ما يعني كما
فعل الماليون والبركينيون توجه الى الى
روسيا اذا اعتقد ان هنالك عده اشكالات
التدخل عسكري له عواقب وخيمه لكن عظم
التدخل ايضا قد يؤديه الى زرع لعدم
الاستقرار في عده الدول وبالتالي اعتقد
بقاء العسكريين في السلطه
يبدو لي امر جد مستبعد انتظار في الحاليه
طالما ان موضوع التدخل العسكري باشكال
الدكتور ادريس ايات هل يمكن ان ينجح على
الاقل كتلويح كتخويف لانه اذا اخذنا مثلا
ما قاله رئيس الوزراء المتاح به ايضا
وحمدو محمود الذي لم يستطع ان يعود الى
البلاد لانه كان في الخارج قال اذا اذا
تسامحنا مع هذا الانقلاب
كانقلاب رابع في هذه المنطقه سيكون هناك
خامس وهناك سادس ولن ننتهي من مسلسل
الانقلابات
نعم استاذ الحقيقه انه قبل الحديث ان
التدخل العسكري كانوا يتحدثون ان اي
التلويح به امامه سيناريوهات قبل التدخل
العسكري اولا هناك الضغوطات هذه اولا
السيناريو الاول المحتمل كان يكون هناك
سلاح العقوبات السلاح العقوبات سيؤدي الى
سيناريو ثاني وهو انقلاب ضد الانقلاب وهذا
يفترض يفترض ان يكون هناك فصيل اخر من
الجيش غير موافق مع الحرس الرئاسي او
القوات الامن والدفاع وانا اخالف السفير
الفرنسي في ذلك ان هناك فصيل او غير متفق
الحقيقه انهم متاجبهه الان متراسه ومتفقه
لانه تعرف ان اذا سقطت سيؤدي الى
اتهام بالخيانه وعقوبات قاسيه عليهم وصلوا
الى نقطه العوده اما السيناريو الثالث انه
السلاح العقوبات يؤدي الى دعم جبهه داخليه
متراصه اذا ما يئس الشعب من العقوبات
وتوقفت المعاملات والموظفون لم يستلقوا
الرواتب ثم بعد ذلك هنالك السينار الرابي
اذا ما نفعت جميع ذلك انه يتحدث عن التدخل
العسكري واعتقد ان التدخل العسكري هو
سيؤدي الى
عكسيه كما ذكرت استاذ والضيفك لم يفسر في
ذلك كثيرا ان الموضوع الهجره موضوع الهجره
لا يؤثر على النيجر بقدر ما يؤثر على
الدول الجوار وكذلك حتى الدول الاوروبيه
لذلك جزء كبير من المنهى الخارجيه التي
توتا لجمهوريه النيجر الهدف منها السد
المهاجرين الغير الشريرين الذين يمرون من
النيجر الى ليبيا او النيجر الى الجزائر
في كل عشره مهاجرين 400 في منطقه غرب
افريقيا ويمرون ابر النيجر اذا هذا
الموضوع اذا انسلاهم ذو حدين فالسناره
الاخير والمحتمل والعقلاني هو سيناريو
التفاوض وهذا بالضبط ما يراهن عليه العسكر
انه اذا لم يردخوا واذا ما حاولوا فقط
التصدي والتحمل لوقت قليل والمقاومه قد
يؤدي الامور الى مفاوضه لكن المؤكد انه
هناك نوع من
الخطاب او اللحد الشديده من قبل انه
التدخل يعرفون انه مر لكن ادم التدخل ايضا
هو ممر
الافلات من الايقاب من قبل الجيش في هذه
المره قد يؤدي الى النتائج محرضه في
المنطقه لذلك ربما سيكون الحل الوسط من
وجهه النظر ان يكون هناك التفاوض على
مرحله انتقاليه قصيره جدا يرجى المدنيين
لكن الحكومه السابقه لا يرضى بها
الانقلابيون ولا الشعب واعتقد انه يجب
ايضا ان ينسى الخلفاء الغربيين هذا الخيار
نعم على كل في سياق التحذير من عواقب اي
تدخل عسكري غربي في النيجر كان موقف
ايطاليا ملفتا للحقيقه حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي انطونيو في تصريح لقناه
رايه الايطاليه انه يجب الضغط من اجل
استعاده الديمقراطيه في النيجر واستبعاد
اي مبادره للتدخل العسكري الغربي الوزير
الايطالي اضاف ان اي تدخل عسكري غربي
سينظر اليه على انه استعمار جديد
وكان وزير الخارجيه الكيني الفريد موته قد
انتقد بشده الاستعمار الغربي للقاره
الافريقيه مطالبا في افتتاح الدوره
الثالثه ولا ضعيف للمجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد
الافريقي الشهر الماضي بحريه تنقل
الافارقه داخل قارتهم دون قيود التاشيرات
التي تعوق التواصل بينهم وتحول دون تحقيق
طموحاتهم في التنميه
اليوم في افريقيا وبسبب تعقيدات التاشيره
اصبحت زياره افريقي لدوله اوروبيه تشبه
محاوله حلب الفيل لكن بالنسبه لاوروبي
يريد زياره دوله افريقيه فان الامر يشبه
التنزه على الشاطئ او تناول كوب من الشاي
لكن ليست هذه هي المشكله
الماساه هي تلك القيود المفروضه على
التاشيرات في العديد من دولنا فبالنسبه
لافريقي يريد زياره زميله الافريقي داخل
الاتحاد الافريقي فان الامر يشبه محاوله
تنظيف اسنان تمساح الاستعمار قسمنا وعلمنا
ان نبتعد عن بعضنا بينما هم يتحدون
ويكسبون الاموال ويحققون التنميه لكنهم
علمونا ان نكره بعضنا لكي نتمتع حقا
بالمزايا الاقتصاديه الحقيقيه لمنطقه
التجاره الحره القاريه الافريقيه نحتاج
الى التصرف مثل الاوروبيين
والسماح بحريه تنقل الاشخاص والتجاره لا
يمكن لوكالات التنميه لدينا مثل وكاله
التنميه التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي وغيرها
ان تنجح حقا عندما تكون هناك كل هذه
القيود فيما بيننا
الامر يتعلق بوضوح بانقلاب لاسباب شخصيه
للانقلابيه كما قلت قبل قليل لاغراض شخصيه
اذا ليس هناك روسيا وراء ذلك او غيرها
هناك فقط مصالح شخصيه اذ والجيش تضامن
كتضامن بين العسكر اذا في المرحله الاولى
صرف النظر عن السيناريو لو ان السيناريو
هو اعاده استئناف العمل بالمكان عليه
سابقا بطريقه سلميه فالامر تطور تدريجيا
نحو ما هو اعتيادي وان الدعم الدولي
للرئيس بازوم سيستمر لكن اذا وصلنا
سيناريا قطاع
قطاع مع بيل مع الدول الغربيه بحيث اذا ما
بقي البقلابيون في السلطه فهذا سيؤدي
للتدهور عام تدهور عام قد تقولون روسيا قد
تستفيد من ذلك ولكن في الواقع ان روسيا
تبيع
مرتزقه لابد من دفع اموال لهم في حين
المساعدات الفرنسيه مجانيه
ومن جانب اخر روسيا تبيع على استحتها ولا
تعطيها مجانا في عنا الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقدم الاسد عليهم
ويجهز الجيش النيجيري مجانا اذا في
سيناريو ان الانقلابيين يستمرون في السلطه
فهذا سيؤدي للتدهور عام للوضع وان الفائز
الوحيد هناك لان لروسيا ولا الاوروبيين
ولا غيرهم ولا مالي ولا بوركينا فاسو
بالعكس ذلك بل كلهم سيتاثرون النتيجه
الضعف يعني النيجر النيجر هي كان نواه
النواه القويه الاقوى في هذه المنطقه
الهشه وبالتالي لو ان
النيجر نهارك كما هو حال بالنسبه بوركينا
فاسو التي يرى الكامل ومعمليا وكذلك الوضع
في مالي يتدهور اذا اذا كان هذا التدهور
يمر بكل منطقه الس الوسطى فهذا
الفائز في هذه المنطقه لن يكون قوه اجنبيه
بل
الجهاديين هم الموجودون هناك هم
المستفيدون الذين فعلا يحتلون اجزاء من
البلاد اجزاء كبيره في مالي واجزاء كبيره
في بوركينا فاسو وجزء صغير في النيجر
وسيمتدون يتوسعون في النيجر وبالتالي
لتصبح المنطقه كلها غير خاضعه للسيطره
النتائج زياده في الهجره ويكون نزوح الناس
وهذا سياثر على الجزائر ولا موريتانيا
وكوت ديفوار وساحل العاجمي كل دول المنطقه
ستتهدد او بوضع خارج عن السيطره في الساحل
الاوسط وبالتالي حاليا هناك
التضامن كبير من الاتحاد الاوروبي وفرنسا
ولد الولايات المتحده لا ننسى ان هناك
قاعده امريكيه بها الف جندي امريكي وفيها
مسيرات ومعدات جيده الجهادين وفرنسا لديها
قاعده في 1500 جندي وهم جزء من جيش
النيجيري وهم هم يدربون الجيش النيجيري
يؤمرون من قبل الضباط النيجيرين وليس
ضباطه
الفرنسيين وبالتالي العام الجيش الفرنسي
تحت قياده الجيش النيجيري ولكن بالنتيجه
للانسحاب اذا ملقي الانتقالابيون وهذا
سيؤدي الى ضعف عام للجيش نفسه وهذا سيؤدي
الى ضعف عام الميزانيه لن تحصل على اموال
وسيحصل على نصف نفقاتهم من الخارج واذا
توقف ذلك حتى لو ان العسكريه لا يستطيع
يحصلوا على مرتباتهم وانهبت السيناريو
كارثيا لابد ان نرى بشكل واضح ان
الانقلابين الجرارات يعني دافع يدافع عن
مصالح انانيه شخصيه على حساب بلاده
وبالتالي هذا هذا هذا البلدي يصيروا
يركضون نحو كارثه واذا لم يحلوا المشكله
بالطريق الاخرى طبعا اسوا اسوا هل هو حل
عسكري في حين ان المفاوضات هي الحل الافضل
ليس مفاوضات لصالح الانقلابيين اذا هو اذا
هو اذا هو سيناريو كارثه كما تراه سفير
نورما خاصه ان فرنسا كما ذكرت لموند
مستاءه جدا لان النيجر هو اخر معقل لها
تقريبا في تلك المنطقه في الدقائق الاخيره
سؤال سريع
لادريس ايات ولا ننهي مع السيد عبيدي هو
ماذا تتوقع في الفتره المقبله بين هذه
الخيارات التي بحثناها لحد الان نبدا
بالدكتور ادريس اياد ثم ننهي مع السيد
عبيدي
نعم استاذ الحقيقه ان الخيار الخيارات
الان او التوقعات من وجهه نظري هناك
توقعات فقط لانه هذه الازمه من بين
الازمات القليله جدا في المنطقه القلائل
التي ترى ان كل جبهه تحاول ان تتمسك
بموقفه فهناك شبه غرور من قبل العسكر
اضافه الى ان هناك ايضا من قبل قوه استرى
عن اي تراجع يمكن ان يفسر بانه اعتراف
بالضعف وكل هذه
كيف المواقف والتسيل المدد لا يؤدي الا
الى مواجهه بطريقه ما او باخرى واتوقع
واتوقع ان سيناريو الاسوا في هذا المجال
بالتحديد لا اقول انه التدخل العسكري لكن
هناك سيناريو اسوا في في الطريق جاي في
سبيل
اسمح لي فقط اشهر الثانيه ان نحدد نكته
اخرى اجدها مهمه وهي انه الاشاره الى اصول
محمد بازون باعتباره من العرب ولهذا هو
هناك الدبات انقلبوا عليه هذا لا يصح ما
حدث ان هناك شراء داخلي في الهز الحاكم
نفسه
وبدرمان الثاني هو نفسه من دفع الانقلابنا
محمد بازون الذي هو عربي قبل بدايه حكمه
بايام وقد قلده وسام الشرف الوطني فلا
اعتقد انه تفسير مقبول الناعم
نرى السيد عبيدي ما السيناريو الذي يراه
للفتره المقبله
اولا ما قاله الدكتور ليس صحيحا حتى في
داخل الجيش في تصريحات مؤخرا تقول بان
محمد لا ينبغي له ان ياخذ الحكم بوصفه من
اقليه وبالتالي حتى تم التشكيك في وصوله
وهذا طبعا
ليس راي الاغلبيه ولكنه موجود
والسكان في الشمال ردوا عليه فيما يتعلق
شخصيا
الوحده بين
مكونات الجيش ليست بتلك القوه الحرس وهي
اهم قوه ضاربه العام وهي المتواجده الان
على الثغور الاساسيه في البلد
ليست لحد ساعه ليست مع الانقلابيين بحيث
ان حتى ان قائد الحرس الان ليس لا زال
يتمسك بشرعيه الرئيس ولا زال يتواجد
يتواجد في قياده الحرس
وكذلك قائد الجيوش لم يظهرن على
الانقلابيين لحد الساعه اذا اعتقد ان اذا
وقع او يتقرر التدخل العسكري وظهرت بوادره
ربما تقع
خلافات عميقه بين القوه الالفيه ظهرت
تماسكها الان مما قد يسهل التدخل في
النجاه واعتقد شخصيا التدخل للنهايه
بنسبه طبعا وليس للغرب
بادره ستتم في الايام القادمه
لان العديد من هذه الدول تخشلان من
تغييرات غير دستوريه تجاهها هي نفسها
وبالتالي اعتقد الاساتذه الخيار العسكري
امام رفض الجيش لتسليم السلطه والتفاوض
اعتقد انه قد يكون هو الخيار
المتاح ولو انه ليس الخيار الاحسن على كل
مع انتهاء المهله الاحد ومع انتهاء اجتماع
رؤساء اركان اكواس في ابوجا ستتضح ربما
الصوره اكثر ما اذا كان الرهان سيكون اكثر
على مزيد من الضغوط ام ان الامور ستتجه في
النهايه الى تدخل عسكري بشكل او باخر شكرا
جميعا شكرا الدكتور ادريس ايات الاكاديميه
النيجيريه شكرا لمحمد عبد الله الطالب
عبيدي الباحث في الشؤون الامنيه لمنطقه
الساحل وشكرا للسفير نيكولان نورمال
السفير الفرنسي السابق في عده دول افريقيا
بهذا المشاهدين الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد معكم باذن
الله الاسبوع المقبل دمتم في رعايه الله
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]